[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE NETTLETON: Hi.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining
us today for the session
From Blobs to Tables,
Where to Store your Data.
My name is Dave Nettleton.
I'm a product manager at
Google, looking after some
of the storage products there.
I'm joined by my
colleague, Robert Saxby,
who's a big data specialist,
flown in especially
from Amsterdam for the event.
So let's get started.
So what we're going
to go through today
is an overview of the
different products
that we have in GCP
for storing your data.
And there is a fairly reasonable
selection of those products.
And so what I wanted to
do before sort of diving
into the name of the
product, and what
it does, and why it's
awesome, I wanted
to step back a little
bit and go through a bit
of historical
context as to, where
did all these products come
from and why, all right?
So we'll go through that.
We'll go through the
products, talk a little bit
about when to use
them, what use cases,
and how to think about them.
And then Robert spends all
of his time working deeply
with customers on
architectures and solutions
out there in the field.
And he'll go through some of the
canonical patterns that we see,
that you might want to think
about for your applications.
And then we'll end.
We'll try to leave
a good five or 10
minutes at the end
for Q&A. Great.
So let's dive in.
So let's go through the
history of storage and database
products.
So if I go kind of
all the way back
from a storage point
of view, originally,
when you attached
storage to machines,
it was physically attached.
So this is direct.
It's called direct
attached storage.
You take a hard disk.
You physically attach
it to a computer.
And that's the storage that that
computer has available to it.
The application, the
file system, the storage,
they're all on a single
machine, a single device
that your application runs on.
So, obviously, this has
a lot of limitations,
but it's kind of
where things started.
And these obviously
still exist today.
So direct attached
storage physically
attach to the device.
Obviously, you start to
run into some limitations
with this, like, huh, what
happens if I need more storage?
What happens if I need to share
my storage between servers?
What do I do then?
This is where you now need
to start to think about,
where is my compute?
Where is my storage?
And what role is
the network playing
in connecting these together?
And two different
models emerged here.
One is a Storage Area
Network, or a SAN.
What this lets you do is it lets
you move the underlying block
storage off of the
machine and put it
into a shared piece of
hardware that often offers
really great
performance, tiering
between different
classes of storage,
whether it's SSD
devices or hard disks.
But the file system
and the application
is still living on the
server or the client.
So you can't really
share that storage
between different applications
or between different computers,
because the file system
it's operating in
is still out there
in that server.
Another alternative is the
Network Attached Storage.
And in this model, one of
the most common examples
is something like a fileshare.
So here, the server
is a fileshare server.
You mount it over the networks.
You go into your
operating system.
You mount a directory or you
mount a share over the network.
And the file system is
remote from your computer
over the network.
And what that lets
you do is now start
to share files between
many different computers.
So if two clients want
to operate over a shared
directory and a
fileshare, they can do it
by using a NAS
solution to do that.
And then these are probably
the most two common.
And actually still today, in
an enterprise on-premises IT
infrastructure, these are the
most common forms of storage
that you'll see.
And more recently, object
storage really started
to emerge as a third
form of storage
for when you have
really large amounts
of unstructured storage,
media files or other assets
that don't need the
super-high performance
and often costly solutions
that are often provided by SANs
and NAS, but gives you sort of
low-cost, large-object storage.
And these solutions,
all of these solutions
are available in enterprises.
And then as you
look at the cloud,
the products that
you'll map to and you'll
hear me talking about
today for block storage
are persistent disk
in both standard
and SSD versions and local SSDs.
So this is our block storage
product for attaching to VM.
For Network Attached Storage,
so for a file system,
we announced recently--
as recently as last month--
Cloud Filestore, which is now
in beta, which is a file storage
product for NAS solutions.
We also have great
partnerships with NetApp, EMC,
and Elastifile, who are also
offering their solutions
as part of GCP.
And then for object
storage, you'll
hear me talk about cloud storage
as our object storage solution.
Maybe one thing to note,
actually, in the cloud,
object storage actually sort
of took off disproportionately
to the on premises use case.
As cloud providers started to
bring storage to the cloud,
actually, many of them started
with object storage solutions.
And so the object
storage use cases
have sort of really
ballooned with the cloud.
So this is the sort of evolution
of the different various
storage products.
It's all really to do with,
where's my file system?
Where's the data?
And where's the network, right?
We'll come back to
that, the importance
of the network in this a couple
of times through the talk.
Databases-- this one's
a little trickier.
So the world of databases was
super easy for 20 or 30 years.
The idea of a relational
database model
where you have
tables, relationships
between those databases, you'd
run your transactional system,
your banking system
against that database.
And if you ever needed to do
reporting or analytics on it,
typically, these systems were a
scale-up, actually often quite
expensive, didn't necessarily
store a huge amount of data
because of the cost in scale.
And if you wanted to run
reporting and analytics
queries against them,
you really didn't
want to run that reporting
query against the system that's
doing your transactional
records or system
of record for your bank.
So what you would
typically do is
you would go through a
process called ETL, so
Extract, Transform, Load.
You would lift up
a copy of the data,
and you'd put it in something
called a data warehouse.
And the data warehouse
was a system specifically
designed for high-performance
queries that aggregated
large amounts of data.
So in the process of moving
the data from your orders
and records and customers
table, you'd move it over
to a data warehouse.
You'd transform the
data in a way that
met the needs of
the queries that you
were going to run against it.
And that's where you would
run your reports and analytics
from.
And those various OLAP
and other technologies
that came along to
help accelerate that
and make that super efficient.
And for 20, 30 years,
major on-prem--
Oracle, Microsoft, IBM
built huge, huge businesses
out of this ecosystem.
And for 30 years,
that was good enough.
And about 10, 15 years ago,
a whole bunch of things
started to happen that caused
a lot of chaos, confusion,
made choices for you
all harder, right?
So what happened?
Well, as the world
became more connected,
the internet
emerged, IoT emerged.
The amount of data
that's getting generated
and that there's an opportunity
to derive value from just
exploded.
I mean, if it's media
assets and other things,
you might put them into object
storage systems and serve them.
But if you want to start to
do analytics over log files,
and other really
large semi-structured
or unstructured
data, there really
wasn't an analytics
alternative for you.
If you put it in your
warehouse, it wasn't really
super well designed for that.
And it certainly didn't--
from a cost point of view, it
would get pretty prohibitively
expensive pretty quickly.
So actually, Google,
some time ago,
introduced this paradigm called
MapReduce, which basically
said, drop all of your
unstructured data into just
the cheapest form
of storage possible.
Store large amounts of it.
And then run jobs against that
to sort of refine that data
and structure it,
count words in it
or look through logs for
quick patterns and analytics.
And it introduced a framework
called MapReduce around that.
That was popularized into the
Hadoop Open Source Project.
Companies like
Hortonworks, MapR, Cloudera
took that further and made
commercial distributions
around that.
So for a while, there was
this interesting dichotomy
in the analytics industry.
The big data vendors will say,
throw away your data warehouse.
You don't need it anymore.
Do everything in the
big data systems.
And the data warehouse folks
were all very confused, going,
what?
Why are they saying that?
You don't need those systems.
Just put it all
in your warehouse.
So that sort of played out
over a couple of years.
Fortunately, now everybody
seems to have settled down,
and everyone recognizes
that these are
sort of complementary systems.
So data lakes are great for
gathering and aggregating
large amounts of data.
And when you want to serve
it for very particular
analytics use cases and it
all becomes more structured,
then a data warehouse
fits in well.
So that's the analytics
part of the world.
In terms of storing
records of data,
though, this whole other
paradigm emerged called NoSQL.
And again, a couple
of sort of patterns
that have driven that were
use cases where, hey, I've
got devices sending me
back huge amounts of data.
I don't really know
the columns that I'm
going to have for
that data in advance.
They might change, or the data
is going to be very sparse.
You could store some
of that and actually
go quite a long way with a
traditional relational database
management system.
But it sort of became clunky
and a bit sort of overpowered
in some areas and
underpowered in other places.
So for something like
large key value stores,
that was a whole other class
of NoSQL products that emerged.
Another pattern
is JSON documents.
So if you have customer catalogs
or other things where there's
a sort of a hierarchical
structure to the data,
as opposed to a tabular
it's just a hard,
round peg, square hole,
to model that into a database.
So a specific class of NoSQL
databases emerged out of that.
And then the other thing
with regular databases,
it's kind of hard to scale.
They scale up pretty well.
Scaling them out is really hard.
So there's now, at the
sort of bleeding edge--
and Google has some
of these products--
to really help customers
now scale their databases
beyond the traditional
confines of what
they've been able to do.
So these have been--
I'll talk to some of the
specifics of the products
we have on this all in a second.
But I just wanted to
take you a little bit
on the journey of
where these came from.
And they're actually all still
evolving as they go forward.
So as I look across all
the different products that
are out there, you
can see some of these
starting to blend and merge.
So be prepared for a
little bit of that.
But there's a very powerful
set of products now
that are much more
niche to use case.
It used to be RDBMS, hammer
hit, use that in all cases.
There's actually more
choice now in terms
of what you can do with the
products and the benefit
you can get from them.
So let me start
to go through some
of the products in a
little bit more detail.
So this is the overall
portfolio that we have for GCP.
So all the way--
I'll start on the right--
so object file and block
products, cloud storage,
persistent disk file store.
Our data warehouse
product is BigQuery.
From the database side,
relational and NoSQL, cloud SQL
Spanner, data store
Bigtable, and then
for caching in memory,
Cloud Memorystore.
I'll go through each of
these in a bit more detail.
Before I do that,
though, one of the things
that is another sort of
trend that has emerged
is this ability to separate
storage and compute.
One of the reasons storage and
compute need to be often tied
together is obviously just
for performance, right?
If your storage and
compute is co-located,
you get much better performance.
That often means
then it's needed
to be physically co-located,
often onto the same machine.
One of the big things that I
love about Google's product
lineup is we've invested
so deeply in the network
capability, both
wide area network,
like you might have heard Brad
talk about in this morning's
keynote, but also in data
center network, the network
within a data center.
Our products-- we can actually
separate storage and compute
from each other physically,
and actually not have it
really affect our performance
in a meaningful way.
And one of the things that
this really fundamentally lets
you achieve is you can scale
storage separate from compute,
right?
And this is a fundamentally
important capability
that lets you really think
about and design systems
in a different way, particularly
in the data and analytics
world.
If you can just gather and
store gigantic amounts of data
and storage without having to
size compute as you go along
with it, even if you
don't know how much of it
you're going to use, it's a
very, very powerful paradigm.
And across all our
products, that's
one thing that we've
done consistently,
is separate storage
from compute.
It actually means that the
products that we can offer
tend to then be fundamentally
simpler because we
made that, effectively, a very
seamless experience for you.
Let me just dive in a little
bit more on the products.
OK, so cloud storage.
So this is basically our fully
managed object storage system.
Very classic use cases here
is I want to store and serve
media, so videos, images.
I want to store
them, serve them.
I might want to back up our
archive, large amounts of data,
or I might want to
create a data lake
and store large amounts of
data for data processing,
and bring a selection
of analytics products
to bear on top of that.
Used across a whole bunch
of verticals-- media,
mobile, financial
services, health
care-- we see this product used
very broadly across the board.
Some of the key features
about this product.
So we offer four
different storage classes.
So you can choose two
location types, multi-regional
or regional storage.
And from there, you
can then tier the data
down into what we call
nearline and coldline.
So this gives you the ability
to have data that's hot,
available to serve
immediately, but tier it down
to colder, cheaper
classes of storage
if you don't need to
access it very often.
And one thing that's very
unique about this product
is we give you a
single API across all
those different storage classes.
So once you put an object
into Google Cloud's Storage
and you get an object
ID, behind the scenes,
you can change
the storage class.
And you can put
it in our coldest
class of storage coldline.
The object ID doesn't change.
And more importantly, if you
ever need to access that data,
your performance in
terms of accessing it
doesn't change, either.
So you basically
get instant access
to your cold archive data, which
is very unique in the industry,
and a super powerful
model for when
you're building applications.
Because now you can just build
your application once, and not
worry about the storage the
class that it's stored in,
and manage the cost and access
to that storage separate
from the application.
So single API across
all storage classes,
millisecond access to
the first byte of data,
takes advantage of
our wide area network
to both bring data
into the platform
as well as to serve
content out, so there's
edge caching built in.
And then another super
important feature
here is consistency,
strong consistency.
So when you write an object
into Google Cloud Storage,
it's immediately available for
all of the compute instances
or analytics instances to see
it immediately and operate over
it.
I'll talk a little bit more
about strong and eventual
consistency, but
strong consistency
is super important for
analytics workloads
when you've got multiple compute
instances reading and writing
against a single bucket.
They all see the same
view of the data.
And that's a pretty big deal
for analytics workloads.
That's Google Cloud Storage.
Persistent Disk.
So this is the classic
I'm running a VM,
I'm using containers,
and I need a disk.
So the disk that we
provide you, it's
not like a physical
disk that's actually
on the same server
in our data centers.
It's actually over the network.
We create you, effectively, a
virtual disk that you can then
attach to these instances.
We provide it as a
single zonal product.
And then we've just
also recently announced
a beta of what we call Regional
Persistent Disk, which actually
replicates synchronously
the data between two zones
within a region, which is
super important for workloads
like databases,
where you might want
to think about high availability
and failover of the database
instance.
So again, we make this
super simple to use.
We offer two tiers, standard
and high performance tiers.
With a single disk, you
can scale it dynamically up
to 64 terabytes.
And we're announcing
at this event
that you can go up to
60,000 IOPS on that.
And again, one thing that's
super interesting, super unique
here is that you don't need
to stripe your disks to get
the maximum performance
out of the VM,
so classic on-premises
IT infrastructure.
You attach multiple disks.
You set up striping,
raid, and other things
from an IT administration
point of view
to get the behavior
that you want.
You don't need to do any of that
with Persistent Disk on GCP.
We take care of all of that
behind the scenes for you.
You just create a single disk.
You run all your workloads.
We balance all of the
operations against it,
and then let you
seamlessly scale it up
to the maximum
performance of the VM.
We also have
management operations,
like being able to take
snapshots against the data.
You can also take these
disks and attach them
to multiple VMs in read-only
mode for often sharing data.
So again, it's super
simple, super powerful,
easy-to-use product
is what we're
aiming for here with our
Persistent Disk for block
storage.
Filestore.
So Cloud Filestore, if
you remember earlier,
I was talking about
the different ways
you might want to access storage
effectively over the network,
and how you think about that.
Lots of applications
have been written
with file storage in mind.
So this is file shares, or I'm
doing video and image editing
in my organization.
I need to share
files between them.
Or I might be-- once I've
done some manipulation
of various image files, I
want to do some rendering
in a render farm.
And I need lots of compute to
access those files, or just
general sort of web
applications like WordPress.
They all operate on
this model of basically
a shared file system.
So with Cloud Filestore,
this gives customers
now a fully managed network
attached file storage--
again, standard and
performance tiers.
We focused very much
on making it easy,
simple to use from both
the price and performance
point of view, integrate
it well with GC and GKE,
and give really just good,
solid, consistent IOPS
and performance.
So this is now in beta.
We announced it
about a month ago.
All right, over to the
world of databases.
So I wondered how
far to go here,
ACID properties, cap
theorem, all the kind
of things you want in an intro
talk on where to store storage.
But I thought I better hit
a couple of the concepts
just because it will help
talk about them later.
So traditional relational
database management system,
you create tables of data,
and they have defined columns.
And then you set constraints--
foreign keys, for example--
between them.
Because you want to do things
like, if I've got a savings,
if I'm a bank, and customers
have multiple accounts with me,
and I want to deduct dollars
from my savings account
and put it in my
checking account,
I've got to make multiple
operations on multiple rows
at the same time.
And I want to make sure
that when I do that,
the whole thing all
happens together,
even though it's happening
across different tables.
So that's called a transaction.
Transactions have
particular properties,
ACID properties, atomic.
If I'm moving data
between two accounts,
all of those operations need to
happen at the same time, right?
So it's atomic.
They all happen together.
Consistent, I'm guaranteed that
when the operation completes,
I leave the multiple tables
and the overall model
of the database in
a consistent state.
Isolated means if you have
several operations or writing
transactions at
the same time, then
they won't interfere
with each other.
And durable says that
once you ACK back
that that operation is
complete, that it really,
really is complete.
Even if the system
dies, it guarantees
to be able to recover
to that point in time.
So this is the classic
properties of transactions.
And I talked a little
bit earlier about
as NoSQL solutions have come
along, some of the trade-offs
that they've made.
And one of the big
things is, as I
think about really wide
columns or document storage,
they, frankly, often don't
need all of those capabilities.
And so we're willing to
make some trade-offs.
And one of the most fundamental
trade-offs they often make
is between strong and
eventual consistency.
Just to kind of
confuse things, this
is a different
type of consistency
than the consistency
on the left.
So strong eventual
consistency means,
as I'm writing data in,
whoever reads it is guaranteed
to see the latest version.
So strong consistency says
every time something is written,
all of the readers see the
latest version of the object.
With eventual consistency,
it means eventually everybody
will see the latest version,
but not immediately.
And that might sound weird,
but there's some use cases
where, if I'm following how
many people like or follow me
on Twitter or something,
whether it's 50,000 or 50,001,
I don't really care as
long as it's really fast
and gets me good enough
results quickly, right?
So I'm willing to make some
trade-offs on accuracy.
But if I'm looking at banking
records, I don't want to--
no, thank you.
I really want to know
that what I am looking at
is the latest copy of the
data, thank you very much.
So NoSQL systems have made
some of these trade-offs.
And I'll talk about the products
a little bit from that context.
So let me start with just the
relational database management
systems.
So Cloud SQL is our
product for fully managed
third-party relational DBs.
So if you're using MySQL,
if you're using Postgres,
if you are kind of sick of
dealing with underlying storage
concepts of replication,
clustering, and failover,
then Cloud SQL is
the product for you.
It gives you all of
the ACID transactions
at the database level that you'd
be familiar with with an RDBMS
system.
It gets you out of having
to manage the underlying
back ends to deal with
high availability,
backup, security
updates, gets you out
of the infrastructure management
and focused on the higher level
values of their app.
You can, of course, take
MySQL and run it in a GC VM,
and attach a disk to it, and
do this yourself, if you want.
But with Cloud SQL,
we let you worry
less about managing and
keeping that service running,
and focus on the higher
level applications,
so used for all of
the classic examples
that you would expect a
good, old relational database
management system
to be used for.
One interesting thing with most
relational database management
systems is they're
basically what I would
call scale-up systems, right?
So if you want
more transactions,
if you want more
storage, you kind of
have to just keep building
a bigger, and bigger,
and bigger system.
HP, for many years, would build
bigger and bigger superdomes
and other gigantic
systems basically
to run really, really, really,
really, really big databases.
And the reason they
did that is it's
really hard to scale
out a database,
because as soon as you
scale out a database,
you end up with data
in multiple places.
And remember, in a relational
database management system,
you want to keep a consistent
view of the entire database.
You've got rows.
You've got tables.
But the unit of consistency
from an ACID point of view
is an entire database.
And as that scales out, it
becomes very, very challenging
to manage that.
In fact, the cap
theorem basically
tells you you get to
pick between consistency,
availability, and
ability to partition.
And you only get to pick
two out of the three, right?
So one of the things
we've built at Google,
we've built it internally
to deal with this problem,
is a product called
Cloud Spanner.
And as you scale your systems
up from an RDBMS perspective,
imagine you want to deal with
a global inventory system.
And you've got systems all
around the world managing
inventory, but you want a
single, common global inventory
system.
What customers would
typically start to do
is they'd start to
manage, and build,
and shard, and come up with
these complex application
constructs to effectively
shard out their RDBMS solution.
So it would be one
application, but they'd
have five different
database servers
that we're dealing with
different parts of it.
And the edge condition--
it just becomes
horrible and gnarly and messy.
If you've ever tried it,
good job, because it's
really, really hard to do.
And you can wire
it together to work
for particular applications.
But it's just not where you
want to be spending your time.
So what we've done
with Cloud Spanner
is actually build a fully
managed relational database
system that can do
transactions at the database
level at a global scale.
And the thing that we've
done that's really unique
is-- you have to make
some trade-off, right?
And what we've
done is, by using--
this is a fascinating story--
atomic clocks and something
called TrueTime,
we've made it so
that the trade-off
on availability
is so tiny that it doesn't
matter from an application
point of view, to all
intents and purposes, right?
So you've got a fully
consistent database.
We partitioned it
across the world.
And we've used atomic clocks
to get synchronization so tight
that we can still get a
five nines availability
as a layer over this data.
So this is an incredibly
powerful relational database
management system
that we've been
using to run some of the largest
systems inside of Google.
I'm really excited
to see what customers
are going to do with this.
This was just beta-ed
a year ago, GA now,
so seeing some super
interesting pick up on this one.
All right, Bigtable.
OK, so that was relational
database management systems.
Now let me switch over
to the NoSQL world.
So let me start with Bigtable.
So here I want to store lots of
records with very wide columns.
So I might have
tens, 100s, 1,000s,
tens of thousands of different
columns that I might want.
Not all the data is going
to have all columns.
It's going to be very
sparsely populated.
It's not very
efficient to pack that
into a relational database.
And the thing that I care about
is that the unit of atomicity--
remember, in a database,
you've got rows and tables
in the entire database.
In a wide column
database like Bigtable,
really, you're only
getting atomic operations
at the row level, right?
So you don't get foreign key
relationships or anything fancy
like that.
What you get is the ability to
write and read row-level data
incredibly quickly.
So this has a single-digit
millisecond reads and writes.
And the trade-off
there is, if you
want to read all of that data,
it's eventually consistent.
So it's good for sort of big
aggregate-type operations.
If you've been using something
like Cassandra or HBase,
which have really
large amounts of data,
and you're having trouble
scaling those clusters,
then we have a
HBase-compatible API
that lets you very easily
move those applications across
to run over Bigtable.
Really great for sort
of real-time analytics
workloads, building out,
monitoring time series,
IoT data sets.
Next, if I now move
from, hey, I care
about an individual
row to I have
now a document-like structure
for user profiles, messaging,
product catalogs,
typically, I'm dealing
with sort of a JSON structure
where I've got a tree of data.
And what I want
to deal with here
is I want a certain amount
of transactional support.
It doesn't need to be
over my entire system,
but I'm going to get it
over a subset of my data.
And eventual consistency is OK.
And this is where the
current Datastore product is.
And if you look at products
to compare with out there,
if I'm running
MongoDB or Couchbase,
then I'm running those clusters.
This is a fully managed
version of that.
So now you wouldn't
need to worry
about managing the
clusters if you switch over
to using Datastore.
There's a couple of other
things on this page which
I'll highlight now.
So at this event,
we're talking about how
we're going to move from what
we call data storage, sort
of second generation
product here.
We're going to be moving to what
we call the third generation
product in Firestore, so
there's a little asterisk there.
So you'll see we
have something called
Cloud Firestore announced.
What we're going
to do is actually
we'll carry forward Datastore
completely backwards compatible
within that.
But we're actually
going to bring even
more of underlying power to it.
So you can still use
that document data model,
but we're going to remove
some of the restrictions
that you have with it today.
So you'll be able to do
transactional support
across the entire store.
And we'll move from an
eventual to strong consistency
model for this as well.
Remember when I was saying
earlier the world of NoSQL
database is
continuing to evolve?
Evolution in
progress right here.
The key thing here
is your data model
is much more of a
document-structured data model.
All right, memorystore.
So great for storing
all of your data,
run through a whole
bunch of stores there.
Now I just want to make my
application go really, really,
really fast.
So you might use something
like Redis for this already.
We offer, basically, a
fully managed version
of that Memorystore, so you
can now cache data in memory
to give you millisecond
lookups for that data
from your application.
Of course, it's not persistent.
The persistence is in
the stores I've already
talked about, but super
fast to accelerate
a bunch of your workloads.
BigQuery.
So I've talked a lot about
regular storage, databases,
and now data warehouse.
So BigQuery is our massively
scalable data warehouse
workload.
You can store gigabytes to
exabytes of the data in this,
running really large-scale
analytics over it.
I've been with Google
nearly two years now.
This is one of my
favorite internal products
when I got here.
I was looking
around and querying,
who's using what
in the products?
So I write a query.
I run it.
15, 20 seconds later, a
result set comes back.
I'm like, oh, that's cool.
How much data did I just query?
I do the count, select.
There's several billion records.
I'm like, oh, yeah,
that's pretty cool.
So this is the really scalable,
powerful data warehouse product
that we have.
It has an optimized
column of storage format
that we manage on your behalf to
just make it work really fast.
You can stream data in at
a really fast rate whilst
querying it at the same time.
We just announced
in the keynote today
that you can actually now build
ML models directly in BigQuery
without leaving BigQuery.
This is a really big deal.
It's really hard for
people to do data science.
This just makes it
easier to build models
so that your organization
can start to leverage them
right from within the tool
that you're already using.
So this is used across
very many workloads,
often as a complement
to something like a data
lake, where I'm storing large
amounts of unstructured data
for surveying and for building
the classic sort of data
warehouse solution on GCP.
And I think, with that, I'm
going to hand over to Robert,
who will take it away.
ROBERT SAXBY: So now we've
gone through all the storages.
I guess, like
everyone else, we all
know which stores to pick now.
That's it.
We're done.
So if you know which
storage to pick,
then that was the
end of the talk.
If you're like me and many
customers I've worked with,
you think, oh, I get it now.
This is what I'm going to use.
And then someone
comes up to you,
but we tried to
use this product.
Well, hopefully we're
going to try and tackle
some of that now, and provide a
little bit more context of how
to choose which storage.
And there are different use
cases we're going to look at.
I mean, some of these are more
of a lift-and-shift type of use
case, and some of
them are going to be
more of the next
generation of application.
Let me just grab a hold
of this, or even this one.
There we go.
So the first couple
I'll show you
are more of a
lift-and-shift type nature.
So one use case, or one
expansion into the cloud
that we see, even if we're
not talking about applications
or different
workloads, is basically
archiving data,
disaster recovery,
and just making that data
available for some other use
case somewhere else later.
So in this particular
use case, it's
basically how do we get data
from on premise to the cloud?
So the typical place
where this data lands
is Google Cloud Storage.
As Dave pointed out,
it's object storage.
The durability is
something like 11 nines,
so you don't have to worry about
backing that data up there.
This is highly durable storage.
So things that you
might want to do here
is, if I'm going to
use it for an archive,
how often do I actually
go and access that data?
So as Dave pointed out, we have
different tiers for pricing
there on a single API.
So this makes it all good.
But then the next question is,
how do I get my data there?
So to get your data to
Google Cloud Storage,
we provide utilities
like gsutil, which I'm
sure some of you already use.
We have the transfer
service, which
is for scheduling larger loads,
and you can check the cache
codes so that you're actually
reading the right objects,
bringing the right
things across.
And we have a whole bunch
of partners out there.
And I just really
put a few of them
up here just to kind of
illustrate the point.
They really operate in the
different areas, so ingesting
data, helping provide
solutions that backup
and do disaster
recovery, so you're
getting your data somewhere,
but then getting it
back again as well.
And obviously, in
that middle category,
you're also thinking,
what application
am I taking the data from?
So you might not be on premise,
reading it from object storage.
You might be reading
it from a NAS.
You might be reading it
from a database system.
So how do I get
that storage out?
You might be reading logs.
How do I get that storage
out into the cloud?
So I know I've got my
backup off premise now,
I know I've got a
disaster recovery plan,
and I can start
archiving as well.
I can start storing maybe
less data on premise.
So these are some of
the things that you
can consider with using
Google Cloud Storage.
And that typically tends to
be the storage medium that
is used in this case.
So the next one is a
bit more complicated,
because it has basically
gone horizontal on all
the different types of
storage we have here.
So let's look at-- actually,
we were having the conversation
when we were putting
this together.
We were trying to define,
what is lift and shift?
And it became very
clear to us that there
were two actual types
of lift and shift.
One is the re-hosting, and
the other is a refactoring.
Now, in rehosting, you
have an application.
It runs, say, on
Windows or on Linux,
and you want to run that
application in the cloud.
Now, that application
requires storage.
If you wanted to
move, for example,
that MySequence, and you want
to do your operation yourself,
and you want to take care of
the maintenance yourself because
of your specific
requirements or they're
slightly different from what we
provide in the managed service,
or you've got
another application
that we don't have a managed
service for, then you
would more the application
across into the cloud,
run it on a VM.
You could run that
in a container
if it was already containerized,
but classically, this
tends to be going into a VM.
And then you've got to
pick what type of storage
do you want underneath.
The storage in this case, the
two that you could look at,
are both POSIX block storage.
You would say
either a local disk,
or if you want to share that
amongst multiple instances,
like have high availability
when you're running that MySQL,
if you're going to have
that in two different zones,
and then you would look at the
NAS storage that we provide.
And again, there are partner
solutions for the NAS as well.
And that might be because you're
already using that partner's
solution on premise.
And it would be a very
natural transition
to use that in the cloud as
well, using the same APIs,
gathering the same
kind of metrics.
So lift and refactor,
essentially,
this is a kind of lift-and-shift
storage where we're saying,
I'm going to move
across, but I'm
going to be using something
a little bit different
underneath, because I need
some different capability.
So let me give an example.
We start, first of
all, with HBase.
HBase typically runs
in Hadoop Cluster.
When you want to
scale your HBase,
then you scale your
Hadoop Cluster.
You scale the storage,
you scale the compute.
HBase will give you
something like--
given a good key
strategy, so you're not
hotspottting your keys,
you'll get maybe, 10 to--
well, somewhat above
10s, probably in 60 to 70
milliseconds of latency
to the first byte.
With Bigtable,
which will be our--
and just for the record,
HBase and Cassandra
are based on that
original Bigtable paper.
So Bigtable will give you,
if you do it properly,
six milliseconds of latency.
It's atomic at the row, so
you have strong consistency
at the row level.
You can now replicate your
Bigtable into multiple zones,
and then you would have eventual
consistency between those two
instances.
But this thing is
linearly scalable,
which is quite a hard thing
to do on your HBase cluster.
And linearly scalable means
that if I have 10,000 IOPS,
or I want to go--
we have customers literally
in the hundreds of thousands
queries per second--
I said IOPS.
I meant queries
per second, sorry--
hundreds of thousands of
queries per second at six
milliseconds latency
across their database.
This thing is like,
yeah, rocket fuel.
That's great.
How do I use it now with
my existing product?
Well, we actually provide
a HBase-compliant API.
So the storage is
quite different.
It gives you some
different capabilities.
It's much faster.
You can scale it linearly.
But you have the same API.
So that rehosting
of your application
becomes quite simple.
Another example
of this is Hadoop.
So if you are moving from
Hadoop, then you're using HDFS.
Again, you want
to decouple this.
You want the benefit
of actually being
able to scale your storage
independently of your compute.
We would recommend
using object storage.
Now, there are a
few limitations.
Object storage is not mutable.
So you can't do appends.
You can't do modifications.
Happens that most Hadoop
workloads now just write out
new files.
Think about things like Parquet.
That works really well
with object storage.
So if you want to move your
Spark job, for example,
to the cloud, you
run it on Dataproc.
The only thing you need
to do is to basically run
that job on Dataproc and
change the HDFS prefix with gs.
And now suddenly, you're able
to use the object storage.
You're able to get
much better throughput.
You can have different workloads
looking at the same storage.
So you gain some
extra benefits there.
But there is a slight
rehosting again,
because you're changing
from HDFS to object storage.
Things like MySQL-- so
you could kind of say this
is a little bit more
rehosting, but we're going
to take the management away.
So that's where the
difference comes in now.
You would find, for
example, your interface
with MySQL, Postgres,
or Cloud SQL
is the same if you were
running it yourself.
But we've taken care of a
lot of the operational part,
the backups, and all
this kind of stuff,
so the rehosting part
there is doing less work.
Sounds terrible.
And the next one is Redis.
Again, it's a very
similar kind of thing.
The rehosting part is that
we are taking away some
of the operational overhead.
So coming back to the slide,
because I think this is--
as Dave pointed out, and as
was clear from my examples
there as well,
this is what makes
Google really special in
terms of the infrastructure.
That network in between,
within our data center,
is 1.3 petabits.
That means 130,000 machines
talking to each other
at 10 gigabits per second.
It's really, really fast.
That means we can consider
storage which is not local
effectively local.
So whether you are attaching
a disk to the machine,
or you're using object storage,
or you are reading data
from BigQuery, you're basically
doing that processing power
separate from where you
are storing your data,
so multiple workloads
looking at the same data.
You can scale out the
storage independently
from the processing.
That's a given.
Where this becomes
really concrete
is, for example, let's say
I need two capabilities.
So I have some data, and
I want to make that data--
let's say I'm creating
recommendations for people.
Now, I have two use cases.
One, I want to be able to
serve those recommendations as
fast as possible.
Now, I could choose to
have those in memory,
in Memorystore.
I could choose to have
them in a key value store
like Bigtable, where I've got
random rewrite access and also
a very low latency.
But let's say I have
another use case as well,
where I want to do analytics.
So I want to look at all the
recommendations I've actually
generated, and I want to see
how they're changing over time,
all this kind of stuff.
Well, in that case, it
might be good to have them
in columnar storage,
because then I
can do big, massive queries,
and aggregate things,
and just select the
column I'm interested in,
instead of selecting
the whole row of data.
So I would store it in BigQuery.
If you look at cloud, you look
at the cost of processing,
and you look at the
cost of storage,
storage is generally
cheaper than processing.
So it makes sense to store
this data multiple times.
Now, if your use
case is ad hoc, you
might say, well,
I don't want that.
Well, then something
like BigQuery
provides federation to Bigtable.
If your use case is I need to
run lots and lots of queries
and I want them
to be really fast,
then you would store
it in both places.
So then you might
start to think about,
how is that pipeline
that's actually
provisioning that
storage-- how can I
provision two sets of storage?
So in this first one, in this
big data and analytics use
case, we're going to look at
two types of data coming in,
so both events.
So this is kind of
streaming data batch.
Your processing could be
with Beam in Dataflow.
It could be through Spark and
you're running on Dataproc.
I'm giving you options here.
There are more.
The point is you can
then go and choose
where you store
this data as well.
So you could be having your
batch of streaming data coming
in, you're processing it, and
the next thing you're saying
is, well, I need to
serve it up quickly.
So I will move it
across and make
sure it's available in Bigtable,
that top one in the middle
there.
I need to run my
analytics, so you
make it available in BigQuery.
Actually, there's a
whole bunch of data
here I just want to
archive because I
want to see how
it's created later,
or it's not in a
structured format yet.
I would need to
change data types
or clean the data a bit more
to get it into BigQuery.
Well, then put it in
Google Cloud Storage.
From there, if you were
going to query that data,
well, BigQuery is native, so
you would have native storage.
Your querying is going to
be optimal, the federation
to the other types of storage.
And then, from that, you
can go and visualize it
with a whole host of
different applications,
or run your models,
or whatever it is
that you're trying to do there.
Another example
I want to give is
a modern, scalable e-commerce.
You can take away
the word "e-commerce"
here and just basically put
any kind of application that
you're trying to scale
for internet scale.
This is how we would
kind of approach it.
This is really kind of the
benefits of some of the things
that Google can provide you.
So for example, our cloud load
balancing-- our load balancing
is global.
I mean, we get great
latency on that.
It will basically allow
you to go and move--
to route the traffic
to the right.
You saw earlier in
the presentation
today how many points
of presence we have.
Our CDN-- so if you've
got data in your bucket
in Google Cloud
Storage and you want
to serve that up
on your website,
you can put our CDN
in front of that,
so it's caching it
on our edge, so we
can serve that up to your
customers as quick as possible.
And then let's take, for
example, the other type.
So the other things that
we might be doing there
is having micro
services, so running
on Kubernetes, for example.
And we might want
to have a backbone,
like a database, a strong,
consistent database that would
scale with the application.
It could also be globally
available as well.
So another point about
Spanner, not only
does it scale horizontally.
You can also run this globally.
That's what we do for
things like AdWords bidding,
for example.
Another example--
Spanner underpins
so much of what we do.
If you look at
Google Cloud Storage
and you use that API
to list the items
in the bucket, that metadata,
again, is stored in Spanner
as a global product.
So if you run a
command and say, what
data do I have in
this bucket, you
won't expect to see any lag
in getting that result back,
and you expect a
consistent result.
So you could use something
like Cloud Spanner
on your own application and
support multiple micro services
running in multiple zones, the
load balancer directing you
to the right microsurfaces
closest to you
to reduce latency, and having
a strong, consistent data
model behind that.
And you may have
things that you want
to put to get even
faster to your customer.
So Spanner will give you
in the tens or the low tens
of milliseconds of latency.
Maybe you have
things that you want
to serve up in your application
even faster than that,
so submillisecond.
User sessions might
be an example.
You might have stuff
from a product catalog
that you really want to get
out as quick as possible.
And for that, you
could use Memorystore.
So hopefully this very
high-level architecture
gives you an idea of
just how you would piece
some of these things together.
So the last thing before
we take questions--
and I realize we're running
out of time, so I will wait--
and I'm sure Dave will as well--
to answer any questions you
have--
is, OK, which storage?
We've gone through
a few examples.
We have examples of
this on the website.
And I kind of went all OCD
on the airplane over here,
as you can see.
So something like this should
only take an hour to create.
But when you want to
fit it all on the screen
and you move it from
left to right 100 times,
then you can kill
at least two hours
on a transatlantic flight.
But hopefully-- I'll just
leave this up on the screen
as we wrap up.
We've spoken about
all of this today.
And this is not the
definitive answer.
This is a frame, a
guide, a decision tree
to help you kind of
work out which storage
to start looking at.
You'll see, for example,
one storage here, Bigtable,
you'll see in multiple places.
One of the questions I get
asked about Bigtable and Spanner
is, which one should I use?
I should use Spanner now,
because Spanner is just
like Bigtable, but then
has strong consistency
over multiple records.
Well, yes, it does.
It has strong consistency
over multiple records,
over multiple tables.
With that comes
a lower latency--
a higher latency.
Wow.
So if you need a
very low latency
and you are only interested
at the row level,
you could consider Bigtable.
So these are the kind of things
that you could think about.
OK, and the rest
of the questions
we will take outside so the
next speakers can have the room.
[MUSIC PLAYING]